one of your books the big short helped
me immeasurably because I was having a
lot of trouble understanding the the
last financial crisis I didn't quite
make sense to me I didn't understand it
so you weren't alone I was not alone I
don't think the Fed understood it but
your book really explained it to me and
then it was made into this terrific
movie and I think a lot of people were
helped immeasurably by it
one of the points you make in that book
is that it was deregulation that caused
so many problems it was people backing
off and saying let Wall Street do Wall
Street let them be who they are
let's leave Malone and that caused
problems do you see that happening again
oh my god yes yeah I mean this is the it
is it's a big problem if you think about
the financial crisis one of the the
thing that interested me in the first
place aside from the fact that these
people who had seen it coming and made a
fortune off the collapse of the of the
subprime mortgage market was you had
these into these banks these
institutions have been sucking in the
supposed best and the brightest from
everyone from the great universities
around the world and that they somehow
came together and committed kind of
collective suicide these were not Unseld
finn teresting people like most selfish
smartest people on planet it's managed
to destroy their institutions and the
way it happened was they were allowed to
they were encouraged to make bets
Gamble's in the market and if again if
they bets worked out they got rich if
the bets didn't work out the taxpayer
got stuck with it right and these
institutions are naturally federally
subsidized I mean they someone's gonna
step in and save them even if they say
they know that I know that and there's
also this Deposit Insurance behind it
that's involved too and so to treat them
like pure capitalist enterprises and you
should be let loose to be basically
hedge fund managers is insane to say the
same thing would happen again
right now that's not to say that they're
not some regulations that might be too
onerous or they my some regulations
might be not so bright but the general
spirit of the Trump administration
coming in and saying like regulation is
bad is nuts
absolutely well also it was not that
long ago it was with you though that we
didn't know if our whole system was
gonna collapse so you'd think that
people would still be fresh in their
minds that we do need some sort of
regulation well and
there's all this is this bigger problem
that I think actually was part of the I
mean you could connect the disaster of
2008 with the Trump election in that you
have these elites on Wall Street who
were who were able to play this game
that was not capitalism you know it was
kind of socialism for the rich and
capitalism for everybody else and the
rest of the society saw that and was
outraged and their the anger in the land
starts I think with that the sense that
there's there's one set of rules for for
elites and another set of rules for
everyone else
you